je considère que nous avons trois cent
mille policiers et gendarmes dans notre
pays bien évidemment il n'y a pas de
racisme d'état ce serait une aberration
que de que de l'affirmer
par contre nous devons avoir une
tolérance zéro je reprends l'expression
du premier ministre sur le fait qu'il y
a malheureusement des phénomènes
racistes dans ce corps et qui a eu tarn
tolérance sur ces phénomènes et qu'il y
a qu il y a eu sûrement peut-être un
laisser-aller qu'il faut absolument
corriger
comment se fait-il que des serviteurs de
la république puisse défendre
de fait à titre privé ou public des
valeurs qui sont contraires la
république donc posons le diagnostic
regardons les remèdes et mettons les en
oeuvre hélas le parlement est à sa place
pour le dire à l'exécutif
vous parlez des rapports entre le
parlement et l'exécutif que pensez vous
du fait que le gouvernement crée sa
propre commission pour enquêter sur sa
gestion du coc vide
ce sont des bonnes pratiques c'est un
retour d'expérience clame l'exécutif aux
jeunes on va écouter quand on a deux
commission denquête qui sont vont se
réunir à l'assemblée au sénat
on ne s'amuse pas permis l'expression a
créé sa propre commission denquête de
fait c'est tout à fait dommageable je
crois que ça nahman haha rien de plus
faisons confiance là aussi aux
parlementaires députés et sénateurs pour
faire toute la lumière sur cette crise
et donc le gouvernement pouvait
totalement s'appuyer sur notre
savoir-faire notre gouvernement
lorsqu'il propose cette enquête de son
côté qu'est ce que cela veut dire
comme ils sont en quête du parlement
j'ai parlé de mépris à l'égard du du
parlement jeu ça peut être aussi un acte
de défiance du gouvernement à l'égard du
parlement alors que le parlement a été
tout à fait à la hauteur depuis le début
de cette crise et donc c'est tout à fait
dommage
dans le même temps gérard larcher est
appelé à contribuer à la sortie de crise
donc emmanuel macron demande est bien au
président du parlement et bien de
participer à tout cela c'est un signe de
confiance de sa part
écoutez c'est bien de consulter le
président larcher où le président
ferrand naturellement mais si c'est pour
créer de la confusion institutionnelle
ou de la confusion politique a créé pour
vous une confusion institutionnelle
parce que quelque part le parlement
travaille fait des propositions fait des
propositions de loi il n'y a aucune
raison aujourd'hui à ce que quelque part
nous devions des collaborateurs
gouvernement l'exécutif doit fixer son
cap et manifestement ce sera le cas
puisque dimanche prochain le président
de l'udc va s'exprimer mais attendez sûr
j'espère que la dimension sociale sera
prise en compte